[Music]
thank you
it's been more than five years since I
moved out of my apartment and began this
journey of traveling full time
and four years of that was spent living
in my van
it's wild to think that after all this
time
this just might be the end of the road
I found mold beneath my floorboards and
water damage spanning nearly the entire
length of the van
it's bad
it's really bad
luckily this all happened at the start
of a two-week house sit in the Tetons so
I've had a place to stay while I tear up
the floor
the owners Stephen Joanne have been so
incredibly kind and helpful with
everything
I honestly can't imagine a better
scenario than this one
even though my house is in shambles
and I don't really know what to do about
it
here is my flooring or at least half of
it what's left of it
and I need to figure out how to get up
all this glue I couldn't get to that
corner back there you can see how
waterlogged and messed up the wood is
you can see it here too I couldn't quite
get under the fridge
this is the situation friends
sucks
I was checking out the pump thoroughly
and there weren't any water leaks when I
was running water there's nothing coming
down
and
there wasn't any water leaking down here
either
so I got under the van and had a look at
the tubing
where it connects to the gray water tank
and that's where I found
a tube that was kind of falling apart I
don't know if you can see this but
I'm gonna try to replace the tubing
[Music]
foreign
it's off by like the tiniest amount
dang it
gotta take it out
[Music]
right there
[Applause]
[Music]
you can only do so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
just change
[Music]
good morning I'm supposed to be in Idaho
Falls right now I am actually leaving on
a trip to Oslo Norway tomorrow I have
not yet packed or
figured out parking for the van or done
any of the 50 million things on my to-do
list that need to be done before I leave
the country
um but I was just really craving being
in the mountains and so I drove here
instead I got here yesterday and I went
for a bike ride and it was so incredible
and then I started pouring rain and I
got absolutely soaked I was just getting
like pelted with raindrops but I just
had this huge like eating grin on
my face because I was just so happy I
just love being out here
um so today I gotta figure out a few
things I have some really crucial emails
to reply to and some work to do I need
to go get food because I'm completely
out and
um yeah I need to work out my timeline
insofar as like making it to the airport
and where I'm gonna park the van and I
need to pack I'm gonna do my best to
film as I go there will probably be a
lot of gaps because there's it's such a
time crunch and yeah I still gotta drive
back to Idaho Falls which is two and a
half hours I'm trying to shoot sunrise
tomorrow trying to shoot sunset tonight
and I have all these other
administrative things to do in between
but I'm going to do my best to just pop
up my phone here and there and take you
along for the ride because this is the
reality of living on the road and also
traveling all the time is you
you gotta like factor in logistics and I
still have to run to the store and buy a
lot of little like travel items for the
airplane
um and we'll see we'll see if we make it
to the airport on time and get on that
plane
fingers crossed I don't know why I do
this to myself but you know when you
just have that feeling where you just
need to be in nature you need to be
outside you need to like
immerse yourself this is like how I fill
my cup energetically and I was just
having one of those moments where I
can't be this close to a place like this
and drive away from it so that's what
we're doing and we're gonna hope for the
best
[Music]
foreign
as I'm recording this
countertops in my van are gone
flooring is gone
the entire bottom half of the van has
been gutted
strange feeling editing this footage
while sitting beside my hollowed out
home
like maybe this was all just a dream
this was my last night in the van before
leaving for Europe
and the last night in my home as I've
always known it
in a way it felt like even the sky was
saying goodbye
[Music]
holy cow
turns out packing in the van is not so
bad because everything's already rolled
and it's all in one place it's like
packing in a giant closet
working way more than I need to but my
flight was moved up four hours I gotta
just throw everything in a bag and run
for it
so I plan to film all of this but
I did not have time for any of that
I was just running and gunning of
everything packed
I don't know if you can see it but
I brought along my bananas
and my cucumber
maybe I can pot them off or eat them I
don't know might be delayed because of
weather and have really tight
connections
they already moved it up four hours
which was completely unexpected
so I'm gonna try to check in and wish me
luck
update bet you're not expecting to see
me in a Walmart parking lot last time we
checked in I was walking to the airport
there was no line at check-in no line at
security everything went so smooth
got into my gate area and got a coffee
settled in everything was going great
and then five minutes before they began
boarding they canceled the flight and
then they canceled the next flight
and then they canceled flights tomorrow
because there's thunderstorms in Denver
which is where I was connecting and I
had a tight Connection in Denver going
to Oslo all my plans just like fell
apart the new plan
currently
is I got my bag I got back into the van
I need to drive to Salt Lake City
tonight and then try to fly out tomorrow
now I think I'm gonna go Salt Lake City
to Paris to Oslo there's a lot of like
weird weather going on right now so
hopefully those flights won't get
canceled but I've got a three hour drive
ahead of me
and I was planning when I got back from
Norway to go back to the Tetons but
now it's going to be a four hour drive
to the Tetons so
I don't know
plans have changed again all right now
we're in a hotel room
in Salt Lake City
which you know I normally wouldn't get a
hotel room but
um the company that I'm flying out with
to Norway it was super cool they booked
a new flight and they got me hotel for
the night so
I got a shower I got a shower I got a
shower hey hey hey
I got a shower today hey
[Music]
we got a two hour drive from Southampton
to the airport where we're catching a
plane from London to Denver Colorado and
then Denver Colorado
Salt Lake City then I have to make it to
a Home Depot before it closes to buy new
flooring for the van
and then get out of the city
find some place to Camp make my way
towards men flakes
there
[Applause]
without a coffee oh my gosh
oh my God
I am taking a shower
here
shower I need coffee shower coffee food
get on a plane
foreign
guys I got flooring a wet shower towel
painting stuff an unpacked suitcase
um I don't even know I'm on my way to
Mammoth I flew in from London late last
night I slept in Salt Lake City and then
this morning I went to Home Depot
started driving and I just randomly
decided to pull over to a rest stop and
it just so happens to be the Bonville
Salt Flats
I haven't been here since like 2015 and
it's really funny that I just randomly
ended up here this is one of the things
I love about living on the road or just
random happy surprises like there wasn't
even a sign or if there was I totally
missed it it's like 100 degrees outside
[Music]
I'm gonna go